Hey, what's going on? It's,
hey, what's going on? Sorry.
Didn't know if this thing was on or not.
It's bill burn his time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday, January seven,
2018 what's going on? How, wow. Yeah. Um,
it's fucking three 32
in the morning and uh,
I slept a little bit,
but just been having a motherfucker of a
time with this jet lagged over here and
you know why it is.
It's cause I'm not booze.
Okay. This one's for all
you alcoholics out there.
I'm fucking with you.
People keep telling me to go get Melatonin
and send natural way to get tired.
Um, all I know is the unnatural way
to get tired, tired, which was, uh,
what I always did was just the first
night I tried to stay up and then I'd go
out and I would just go get,
I'd go booze and I'd have four fucking
stiff drinks and just come home and pass
out. And then I'd start to
get acclimated to their time.
I'd have to do that about three nights
in a row and that I was fine. Um,
so whatever.
I just been,
so I got to do this fucking
podcast because today I'm
getting on a plane and I'm
flying to a stonier to
do one show tonight.
I'm very excited about it. I
googled some pictures, first of all,
Astonia Jesus Christ.
What a bad ass flag.
That's one of those things that I collect.
I don't buy a lot of touristy shit,
so I just get those little flags.
So I gotta make sure I get the time
to go down and pick one of those up.
Then I got love for you the next day.
This is the part of the tour where I
start going to all these places I've never
been to as far as countries goes. But, um,
the last two nights I started in
Cologne. I had been there before. Um,
we did Munich on Saturday and
yesterday we did often back often buck.
And um, it's just been a fucking great
time being over here with the burrows.
Sorry, my voice is
going through, you know,
I'm trying to make sure I have
good shows and I don't know.
I don't know what the
fuck I did to it, but, uh,
yesterday I should say Saturday and Sunday
we had two shows Munich to and often
buck. And the first fucking
show was like at 3:30 PM.
This is what kills me.
I've never in my career that I can really
remember ever gone on stage like that.
I mean at that time,
I think maybe one time I was doing
hilarious and Cleveland and I did an
afternoon show, but I think that was
at like four or five, I don't know,
just three 30. It was fucking
weird, but I got to tell you,
the crowd was unbelievable.
Munich crowds were fucking ridiculous.
I mean, they've all been great, but they
were just like, we were in like this,
I swear to God that fall it goes
on like a little barn and um,
it was like snowing out and I had to walk
from the green room back outside into
the snow and then back into
the venue and I was just like,
these motherfuckers are
trying to get me sick.
So my coat on their big stupid palm
palm hat that I got in Finland,
where back in the day, which has been
saving my ass, that the vitamin C pack,
it's in a bowl shows.
The crowds were just crazy good.
And uh,
in between shows I ran around
trying to find my daughter's,
some sneakers, some cool sneakers. I
have found this store called early,
somebody told me about.
And uh,
we drove over there and I bought
a couple pairs of sneakers.
I go to the forest Gump once, you
know, the classic Nike Cortez.
And I made sure that I got the,
uh,
the Velcro straps so she can get a little
fat fucking Tyler feet and they're,
you know,
um,
but it was pretty fucking cool because
in the middle of the city they had this
giant, giant wall going on, you know,
and it couldn't see how it could,
we just literally drove by and it
was the original wall of the city,
um, for like back in the day
when there was just like,
you know,
it was a free for all.
He just sat in your village and all of a
sudden some fucking assholes would just
show up and just start murdering the man
and rape and the women in and shit on
fire. And it was just like, like
that's what people did back then.
Like that was like a fucking like
something that someone has spired too.
They aspired to rape and pillage
and he just fucking lunatic shit.
So these people you know,
wanted to survive.
So they would build these giant walls,
I guess around their fucking villages.
Then someone's trying to tell me a teller.
The Hud used to save the bodies from the
previous village and then he'd sneak up
on a village,
he'd late,
the body's on fire and then with like a
catapult would start shooting them into
the fucking village he wanted to attack.
Like you just sitting there chilling out,
enjoying yourself and like all the sudden,
you know,
I dunno what was the job back then?
Some fucking copper Smith comes through
the top of your fucking little hut.
They're on fire and lands on
your God damn dinner table.
And that that was,
that was the first sign that your life
was going to fucking change. I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ. It's crazy. And I,
I don't know what it is about Europe
maybe cause I watched all this shit about
World War II and it, you know, and a
lot of, you know, American history,
they don't give a fuck about,
um,
you know, the whole curriculum was
designed by white descendants from Europe.
So that's all we fucking talked about.
So you just know certain
shit and of course they, you,
they dance around a lot of shit. Um,
but as I've been over here, like we,
when we took the train from fucking
Munich up to often Bach, uh,
they will like next stop like Nuremberg.
And I'm like Norenberg
like Nuremberg trials.
For some reason I thought that that was,
those trials were in France.
And now that I'm getting exposed a little
more of the German language, I'm like,
well, obviously that's not
a fucking French city. Um,
okay.
So I'm on the train and I'm
texting version to be like, dude,
this is where they fucking try it. All the
Nazis, the SS and the Gestapo and shit.
After World War II when they like, they'd
like fucking put him to death and shit,
hanging them and everything. And uh,
I'm texting him and he can't fucking,
yeah, he's not getting service. So Mike
Versie Versie he looks up, you know,
he's a couple seats away, you know, but
out of the respect for German people,
I don't want to be like,
hey,
this is where they fucking killed all the
Nazis have to function. World War Two.
I walked over to him and I started to
say it, but because I'm speaking English,
people just look at you like, oh, these
are fucking American. What's judge him?
Is he fat? Is he breathing through
his mouth? You know, is he loud?
So I just literally had
to show him the text. Um,
and I'm sitting there, you know,
like when you go to fucking Berlin,
that's where Hitler killed himself
in part of his bunker. Still exist.
I know they, they fucking destroyed
most of it. The Soviet state.
And then they build just like an
apartment building around it. You know,
it's like Los Angeles.
How they do that shit.
They just knocked shit down and they
don't give a fuck what happened.
And I get it. Cause the guy was so fucking
evil. But like, I'm just like, wow,
it's so fucking crazy that peep the German
people just walk amongst all of this
shit. And then I was like, wait a minute.
I live in the United States of America.
I go down south all the time.
I can't imagine what the fuck happened.
Right where I'm sitting when I'm
sitting in a fucking waffle house.
Like if that used to be like a plantation
or some slave was running away and
they got caught and God
knows what the fuck happened.
Forget about the native Americans.
So I was like, well, why the fuck
okay.
Do I only think about that shit you
don't like every time I go to Paris,
like when I look at this, Sean's
Elisa, that fucking street,
I just pictured when the Nazis
fucking paraded up the damn thing.
Uh, when the occupied their
country and when the allied forces,
when they took it back.
Um,
I mean all the French ladies banged
a bunch of Americans of identity. Um,
how come I don't think of that shit,
my own country.
It's just cause cause I grew up there,
it's fucked.
I almost thought that
would be like a weird,
yeah.
When those Saifai fucking movie
slash horror movies that um,
I don't know if you just, if you, I
get them because they kind of do it.
They do it on like light shit.
Like if you move into a house and someone
got murdered there in the 20s, right?
Like let me tell something.
She,
I'm going to just let you from
fucking history here. Right.
Then all of a sudden
that place is haunted,
but they don't like maybe American horror
story did it. I don't fucking know.
I watch sports, but um, anyway,
um,
okay.
And then,
then I'm reading all of this shit and
it's like about the Nuremberg trial when
I'm on the fucking train and making sure
nobody's looking over my shoulder and
I'm seeing how like they had to decide
how they were going to go sort of the
first time I think of World War One,
they tried to do it,
but this is the first time
they were trying to make
people pay for their fucking
war crimes.
So you know,
FDR and fucking Churchill and all
these guys are trying to figure out how
they're going to go about doing it.
And FDR balked at something and then
he died and then Truman came in and was
just like,
well wait a minute.
Okay,
yeah. Truman came in and was like,
no, we're going to do that shit.
So he must have still
been at war with Japan.
And then he goes and he drops to fucking
nuclear weapons on fucking Japan.
Like it was, it's like they were
all fucking world war criminals.
We sitting there firebombing
Dresden and shit.
It's like women and children down
there. It's, it's cell. I don't know.
That's why I always say like,
to this day,
I can't believe that like
war is still a legal,
you know, slash like glorified. And uh,
I mean, I understand defending
your country and shit like that.
If there's a fucking lunatic out there,
but like, you know who's kidding,
who you know a lot. You know,
there's been a lot of iffy decisions
made out there for, you know, it's just,
it's a fucking land grab you going
after oil, you know, you, you want,
you know what that land, because it's,
it's got some water around it. I mean,
that's why people go to fucking war most
of the time it seems nowadays. Anyways.
Um, but anyways, I dunno,
some of that leads to me to talking
about fucking thin privilege.
I follow this guy, Yannis Pappas
on the Instagram. He's like,
fucking genius does all these characters
and stuff. So I'm always watching him.
Kyle done again. Jeff Richards,
they're like my favorite,
like the fucking characters. They
do the fucking geniuses, right?
So I was watching his and he posted
something about it. So I'm going,
what the fuck is thin privilege? I
already know. I have white privilege,
evidently I have been privileged to like
if it was like monopoly and there was a
stretch, a little properties that
were the privileged properties.
Like I feel like I got some of those
little green houses on a lot of them.
So evidently it's a privilege.
Yeah.
To be thin rather than a reward
for having the discipline.
Yeah.
To push yourself away from the
fucking table. You know? And I'm not,
I'm not talking about when
you were a kid and you just,
some people have baby felt like I had
baby fat. I was a fat fucking kid.
I was like 10 pounds. You
know, when I was born,
I was a big fucking read Charlie Brown.
Look at fucking baby.
There's not one to picture of me till
I'm like three in my head was literally
almost the size it is right
now when I was at adult.
Like I literally from day one look like
I could fuck up a Lego city. Right.
And um,
okay.
You know,
if I just use that to my advantage,
that'd be on the playground and people
be fucking with me cause my orange hair
and I just lean on him, you know, like a,
like a boxer that just wearing
them out in the early rounds.
And then I just fucking,
you know,
bunch of body shots and it would be over
me with my big flabby freckled arms.
And then somewhere in like junior high,
I just sort of leaned out like all of
a sudden I grew a little bit and uh,
and then I stopped growing and
then I was just a small skinny kid.
I kind of had it all, you know,
when it comes to the bullying,
I was a fat kid when I was
really young that I was, uh,
but I was big and then I became small
and I was skinny and you throw it all in
there.
I had orange hair,
so it was kind of inevitable that I was
going to end up being some sort of a
fucking comedian or something.
I Dunno what, but um, anyways,
this then privileged shit.
It's like,
they're like people who are thin need
to fucking acknowledge. You know,
it's up to you to realize how
privileged you are that, you know,
people don't judge you when you eat a
cookie in public and above about and all
this shit.
This ain't well golf.
Do they fucking judge me when
I put on a pair of shorts,
I look at how fucking white my legs
are. You know, these fucking people.
You know what kills me about Shit
like that? All right, I get it.
Where you shouldn't tease fad people
and make them feel bad and all that,
you know, it's fucking immature
and it's me, I get it. Right?
But on the other side,
it's like there's no,
there is no burden of responsibility.
It's something that's
totally fucking curable.
And I know some people literally have
like food addictions and like it's a
psychological thing or whatever. But
you know, for most people who are fat,
it's just, you've just eaten
too much fucking food. You know?
And considering most of the
goddamn world is starving,
you know,
it's just like,
can you understood leave
with this train of thought.
Fat White people in a first world nation
can literally walk around and call
themselves victims. Well, you know,
I don't know all of these
fucking fatties I swear to God,
that's why I did that bid
on it at my last special.
You need to go to some countries where
the people are really have some problems.
I mean, you can even go to score on
the fucking Internet and read about it.
He could fill a hell of a lot fucking
better about yourself. You know,
I was sitting there, uh, you know, I was
getting frustrated with being fucking, uh,
jet lagged and ship and these three 30
in the afternoon show is, I was like,
fuck man,
now I can't fucking sleep.
And I was like feeling like I was a Zombie
and I was getting all grumpy and shit
and then I could go on the Internet
and I'm like, wait a minute. Okay.
So if Nuremberg is here, where was
Auswitch us? I can only say it right?
The concentration camp police,
right.
And it turns out it's in Poland and I
was like, well I don't have the time,
it's going to be too far away.
So I kind of googled some
fucking pictures of it and shit.
And I looked at it and I was like, oh
my God, I could never fucking go there.
I mean literally like you're fucking
blood runs cold, like looking at the shit.
And then they had like,
you know,
pictures of like piles of
like kids shoes and shit.
And I'm literally buying shoes for
my kid and I'm just like going,
am I really bitching that I
have a three 30 fucking show?
Kind of a fucking asshole.
Am I right?
I think people eating
fucking hot fudge Sundaes.
I'd do that every once in a while.
You know what I mean?
They got to look up a bunch of starve and
fucking kids in the middle of nowhere.
Not even in the middle of nowhere,
in the middle of where the world for
whatever reason considers nowhere before
you sit there and try to like figure
out a new way to try and fuck up.
Some of these career cause
that's going to be another thing.
This is such a weird fucking time of so
many God damn people like they just keep
trying to like,
I keep looking at it like a bike race.
Like they try to get behind somebody
who has like a legitimate complaint.
Like I gotta be honest with you,
the fact that white women can fucking
use the term white male privilege and
they're like a white woman,
the United States of America.
The fact that they can somehow hop on
the other side of the fence as some sort
of like, you know, um, underprivileged
group. And I'm not saying that,
you know, they don't get less than
white males, but it's just like,
should I really be listening
to your complaints next?
Are you really going to be first in line?
You actually have white privilege when
it comes to complaining because people
are going to pay attention to your shit
first even though you're suffering the
least. Right. As far as my
complete lack of research goes,
as far as me babbling here, fucking
foreign the goddamn morning in our real,
I hope I'm that weekend,
somebody up mumbling here. Um,
anyways,
so I guess that's the latest thing
that can get you to not fucking,
I dunno, sell some tickets on
the road or a fucking, you know,
host an awards show, like
whatever the fuck we're going
to do. You know, you know,
it blows my mind about that
whole ward show scandal is,
I just love how whatever was said was
said around 2011 and all these adults who
were well old enough,
well old enough,
we're plenty old enough to have gotten
offended back then and made a big stink.
And for some reason it
doesn't fucking come out.
It's almost like they get you on
something that like, all right,
hold onto that card.
You know what I mean?
Like they playing grantee fucking
water and then they wait till you get
something big enough that's going to
shine a light in their cars and then they
come back and they fucking train,
slam it down on the fucking table. Um,
I was out of the country,
but as far as what I read,
Ellen degenerates as cool in my book for
the rest of the fucking time, you know,
and I thought whatever she was trying
to do as a pho is the way to go about
stuff like that where you
just don't try to fucking
destroy somebody. You try
to get them, see your point,
try to get people on your side to be,
hey, give this person another chance.
You have it.
Be Open like that.
You open it up to a discussion and then
people just watch it and learn some shit
rather than just being like,
this person said this,
now they can't have that now let's watch
them fucking, you know, lose something.
You know who she's just sitting there
watching for the fucking entertainment
value. Um, this is one of my
favorite things to do by the way,
is to get out of my fucking high horse
here and preach at a quarter to four in
the fucking morning, whatever fucking
time it is here. Um, all right,
let's talk a NFL playoffs.
I missed most of them.
I was able to watch a little bit
of that eagles bears game, um,
in German, which was pretty cool. Um,
cause he kept enough of the English words
that I was able to, you know, kind of know
what the fuck they were talking about.
And uh, I know everybody's going
to get on the bears kicker,
but can somebody please explain to me
why the fuck you go for a two point
conversion.
When the bears did that,
why not just fucking kicked the goddamn
thing and then you end up losing by one?
John Madden my entire fucking
life said he'd take the points.
You'd take the points,
you'd take the points,
those extra points come back to hot
yet I know this guy, I missed that.
I guess he hit a number
of fucking gold posting.
He hit the CROC goalposts
and the crossbar.
And the last one I watched the highlights,
but why the fuck are you going for
two points there? Makes it just,
you know,
well choose you only up by two.
You're acting like it's the end of the
game with the fucking two minutes to go.
There's a whole bunch of time left
and I forget when it happened,
the end of the third quarter,
beginning of fourth quarter,
but there was plenty of fucking time.
We're just a complete non factor.
Just take that extra fucking point.
Just take the fucking thing and then
see where the fuck you are with the last
five minutes.
Then you start playing that game.
You know everybody's going like Patrick,
one l like pulling the fucking goalie
with like 10 minutes left in the game,
which for some reason actually worked
for him. So congratulations to uh,
to the eagles, to Nick's falls,
man. But by the way though,
that matched her bisky
man had a brisk is acs.
Then we had a fucking break game
two for over hundred yards. Um,
I thought he was like really accurate and
he was dealing with like the defending
Superbowl champions. I thought it
was great to next falls is that gate,
you know, like I just
fucking delivers. Um,
okay.
Oh my God. Pete Carroll, Jesus
Christ, the poor fucking bastard.
The poor fucking bastard man.
He's getting a ton of shit in Seattle.
I guess they thought he ran the ball too
much and uh, I don't know what happened.
That field goal kicker get fucking hurts
and then they add their punch puncher
there and he has to do an onside kick.
Like why didn't he just
do what they all do?
Just stick it on the tee and then you
kick the ball in a downward motion on the
upper third of the fucking ball. So
it pops up in the air. The guy just,
he fucking just fucking basically
lobbed it down the field that you know
something.
Okay.
If Pete Carroll never won a Superbowl
and they were going to make a statue of
him,
it would be him with his hands on his
fucking knees just looking down at the
ground in pain.
He sorta the urban Meyer of a NFL coaches,
you know, and that they both won,
but they just have that fucking,
they just said that, that's soul crushing.
Whenever I see him do that. You don't,
it reminds me of, it reminds me
of Carl Yastrzemski when he back,
who's backing up to the wall?
When Bucky dent hit that three run homer
and you just saw his legs buckle. Okay.
It just reminds me of that every time
I see that shit. So, um, I dunno,
my condolences. I don't usually
have condolences to Seattle fans,
but I dunno if the rivalries kind of died
down. You football fans, I feel for you.
I've been there and all that shit.
Um,
congratulates the San Diego chargers
and I forget who played the last game.
All the colts, I guess the colts
look good and Andrew luck is back,
which is great.
Um,
other than that, I haven't been
fucking doing anything here.
I should probably do
some of these reeds here.
It's a podcast might be a little
short because I have to get up,
go to the airport. I'm already
up. All right. Oh, look
who's here. I can't do this.
Read justice everybody.
I apologize. It's old zip
recruiter.
You know what SMAD figuring out who
you need to hire to take care of your
business to take your business
to the next level in 2019.
You know what else is
SMAD start the new year?
I've strong by going to
ziprecruiter.com/berta Heiner
the right fucking people.
Unlike other jobs. I wonder if now
when you go to hire the right people,
they should add to zip recruiter.
It also goes through all your,
you're always a tweets you've ever sent
out to make sure someone's not going to
be like, you know, I wanted to
rent a car from this person.
And then they'd said this
tweet in thousand nine,
making fun of people with ugly feet.
I have feet that are,
they wouldn't say ugly.
How would they say it?
I Dunno.
Visually challenged. Um,
unlike other job sites,
zip recruiter finds qualified
candidates for you. It's powerful.
Matching technology scans thousands of
resumes to identify people with the right
skills,
education,
and experience and actively
invites them to apply to your job.
So you get qualified candidates fast.
That's why zip
of recruiter.
Yeah,
it's a German version is rated number
one by employers in the u s this writing
comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over 1000 reviews.
And right now my
listeners can get the zip.
Yeah,
recruiter for free at
this exclusive websites,
ziprecruiter.com/bar
if you love this show,
show you support to an end ZipRecruiter
by going to ziprecruiter.com/burpee you
are our, that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar ah, ah.
So my voice is going out trying to do
the German guard and every movie Zip
recruiter, the smartest way to
hire. All right. Policy genius.
Um,
getting life insurance is one of the more
intimidating parts of becoming a full
fledged adult.
It's not that bad if you have kids.
It's weird if you get it and you
just have your wife, you know,
cause then you're like,
is this bitch you going to kill me
once you have the kid you like how
I want them to be. All right. Sorry.
I watch a lot of those fucking first 48,
uh, it, it always comes down, you know,
first time murderers. So much of it
comes down to life insurance. Uh,
am I not selling this right?
Well right now I don't think I am.
There's so many options.
It's hard to know where to start,
but making sure your family is financially
protected is too important to avoid.
This is what you do once
you get life insurance.
He just sort of monitor your wife's laptop
or your husbands if they're checking
out,
like you know how to dispose of a body
or the check it out when the tides go in
and out.
That I think you might want to
put a little addendum to your policy.
So policy genius creates a website that
makes it easy for you to compare quotes
and get advice and get covered
without extra fees or commission.
A sales agent motivate your audience.
Talk about your experience
with the product. Slash.
Service. I've never used it,
but I got life insurance and
now whenever I hit turbulence,
when I'm flying or whatever, I don't
worry about it cause I'm like, well,
you know what? As much as they're
going to miss me, it's you know,
they're going to be, they're
going to be all right. Uh,
and the House won't be as loud.
Uh,
choose one to two copy points to
rotate into your spot. All right,
I'll read the first two.
Policy Genius is easy way to get life
insurance and minutes you can from quotes,
from top insurance to find the coverage
you need at a price you can afford.
From there,
you can apply online and the advisors
at policy genius will handle all the red
tape to even negotiate your
rate with the insurance company.
It's all part of their
best price guarantee.
That's great because it's a shit show
trying to find the right one. Uh,
if you've got intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past,
try starting your
search@policygenius.com and minutes.
You can compare quotes and apply.
You can do the whole thing
on your phone right now.
Policy Genius easiest were to
compare and buy life insurance.
Oh fuck. How am I going to do this?
Read justice with my voice here, honey.
Um,
you probably heard me talk about honey,
the free browser extension that
automatically helps me save money on,
oh my favorite sites.
But did you do that?
Honey even makes Amazon
better with Millie and dude.
Fuck Amazon. Who's fucking
cons? Those assholes.
They throw it over the fence.
They consider it delivered.
There is no return address. You never can
figure out who the fuck sent it to you.
It's a fucking nightmare with millions
of sellers on Amazon offering the same
products. How do you know if you're
really getting the best price?
How the fuck do you know if it was
delivered? There's no fucking phone call.
You got to bring it back down to a shop
and they're just little little flows.
We can tell it was delivered.
We could formed it. Uh,
that's where honey comes in.
What? Cause the fucking
driver said it was confirmed.
Honey automatically goes to wear to work.
Whenever I shop on Amazon,
I ordered this other shit on Amazon.
It's fucking, and I never got it.
I didn't know what the fuck is.
It compares the PR.
This is like the worst
advertising read ever.
It compares the prices of every seller
that carries the item. I want honey,
even factors in shipping,
sales tax and Amazon prime status to
make sure I'm getting the lowest price.
It shows me the best delivery
time, even if Amazon doesn't. Um,
it's like having my very own personal
shopping assistant. Of course,
Amazon does it.
He can't fucking get anybody on the phone.
More than 10 million people
are using honey to save money.
Honey is so has over a hundred
thousand five star reviews on Google.
Maybe I need honey, so Amazon
will work better for me. Um,
the five star reviews on the Google
Chrome store at Time magazine says it's
basically free money. So the next time
you're in the world's biggest marketplace,
looking for the best deals,
treat yourself to the free
upgrade that makes Amazon better.
Add honey for free@jointhoney.com slash.
Bird that's joint honey.com/.
Bar. That's hilarious.
I'm making fun of Amazon and
everything that they don't do well,
honey actually fixes it.
So in a way I was selling it because God
knows where I'll still gonna use Amazon,
right? All right, last radio a my bookie.
How the four key door or you're doing
your fucking degenerate NFL playoffs are
here and it's time to get into
the edge with my bookie. Um,
don't be that guy with no rooting
interest as your relatives or friends sit
around watching the game.
Not this year when the 53rd
super bowl is around the corner,
it really 53. Holy. I've been
watching since Superbowl 12.
Fucking um, it's real. It really
is the most wonderful time of year.
Make sure you're ready for the daily
action by signing up at my bookie today.
They pay fast.
When you win.
Ownership really cares about good customer
service and they offer the craziest
props when you bet it's just as
important as who you're betting on. Oh,
where are you? Where are you bet it's
just as important as who you're voting on.
And if you wanted to make
money during the bowl season,
you got to go to my
bookie. I trust them. Uh,
but you don't have to take my word for it.
Check them out for yourself.
Join now and my bookie,
we'll offer you a 50% deposit bonus
to make sure you have a nice bag rope.
Nace fork and bank role for both season.
Use the Promo Code [inaudible] when
you deposit to activate the offer,
that's Promo Code Bar at My bookie.
How the fucking door you pay you
when you get paid. All right,
where am I at here?
30 fucking minutes.
Shit,
I opened up getting sick here.
How much you fucking vitamins
CD you have to take. You know,
can we grab one of these goddamn
packets and I'll drink one now. Dude,
this fucking hotel,
I can't figure out.
I can't figure out how to turn on
the fucking heat, you know, but I,
one of the things,
the only thing I hate more than not being
able to turn it on on the fucking heat
is having to call down to the front desk
and then they got to send somebody up.
I just, I, I, I'd rather
sit here and get sick.
There we go. A little bit of
fucking often buck bottled water.
Maybe I can get seltzers on my podcast
to advertise a little fine with see
packet here.
This is how you do with,
hey, did anybody else on Twitter see
that? Hilarious little, I don't know.
Is it a Gif? Is that, is that a picture?
I don't know what the fuck you call it.
You Know Bell Biv devoe somebody made one
that was Belbin and Willem defoe so it
was belt before default.
And that's the kind of shit that's the
kind of shit that I fucking love it.
I love that silly shift.
Um, all right, there we go.
Christ bills, stirring it with
your finger. You're fucking animal.
What is wrong with you? Um, all
right, down the hatch. Here we go.
Um, all right. So anyways, yes,
we ordered room service
as far as I can tell.
The top three things on room
service in Germany are, uh,
I hamburger diener Schnitzel or spaghetti.
And I actually, when I was in
Munich I got some dean or Schnitzel,
which I always thought was
like a fucking hot dog,
but I saw pork cutlet that's breaded.
It was fucking delicious.
Um,
that's what's killing me about being
here in Germany as I haven't had time to
get like a proper German meal. Uh,
just been traveling so much and uh,
you know, I, I'm never
going to do ancestry.com,
but as far as the names of my family tree,
I know I am mostly German.
MMM.
I love this shit. I was fucking
sausages and fucking beer and all that.
It kills me. I'll tell you the
next time I come here to Germany,
which I'm definitely going to do
because it's been so much fun.
I am going to be beyond off the wagon
and I'm trying all these fucking be,
I'm going to book myself
out here in October fest.
I wouldn't buy a little beyond October
fest outfit outfit and I'm going to
fucking drink my ass off,
but not on this tour.
Oh, Billy. No Fun. It's coming up on 50
days. It just being a fucking douchebag.
Um, anyways, so let's plow ahead here.
Let's read some of these
fucking thanks for the week. Uh,
just another one about Poland.
All right.
Very excited to go to Poland to very
excited. They've got a bottle, Berlin.
All it like all the rest of this tour
is just going to be just a bunch of bar.
Yeah.
It's just a bunch of Shit I've never seen.
I would speaking to that guest who
came out to the show last night,
guess who the fuck showed up?
One of my favorite drummers,
one of the greatest drummers in the world,
Benny grab
showed up with his lovely girlfriend.
I hate naming names and everything,
but everybody knows who the
fuck he has, right? Yeah.
MMM.
He fuck, I couldn't vote. You know,
I, it's just, it's unbelievable. Um,
if you're a drummer out there and you
want to see somebody who possesses one of
the rare things in drumming,
which is incredible feel passion,
playing from the heart
combined with ridiculous chops.
And the thing that I've found with,
with drumming is when
you get those chops guys,
a lot of times when they play
there between their ears,
like they're in their head and they have
all this really intricate shit but it
disconnected to who they are as a person.
And then if you have like a group player,
you know,
if they go to take a solo,
if they even do, it's uh,
you know, it's still good because it's
still grows, but it's not like the crazy,
uh, I dunno, I'm just saying those guys
that have those fucking insane shops,
we would think even buddy
rich will be going like, dude,
what the fuck are you
doing there nowadays?
How far drumming has come because
everybody, the Internet's,
but basically everybody's
watching everybody.
Everybody's jamming and
learning from each other. Uh,
it's just so rare to meet a guide that
has his chops and plays the way he does.
So he does clinics all
around the world and uh,
he's got some DVDs out there at all and
there's no fucking way that you won't be
tremendously changed for the better if,
if you start watching his videos.
So it's Benny, Benny, Greg, B.
E n n y, g. R, e B I believe.
I'm not sure if this too,
I can't fucking spell anything.
Just check them out if you
can. All right. Anyways,
just another one about Poland.
Uh,
Dear Mc run from the sun.
I like that one.
Uh,
I am honestly thrilled then in a few
days you're going to show up in my not so
beautiful city of Warsaw.
Don't tell me that. Well,
I live in a not so beautiful
city of La and I love it.
I like how it's gritty and grimy
and all that Shit, you know? Sorry,
drinking, modified. Ever see
here? Uh, mainly because um, okay.
I'm honestly thrilled that you are going
to be in a few days and you're going to
show up.
It might not so beautiful city of Warsaw,
mainly because I'm selling my house and
you are so white that you're rising the
property value whenever you arrive.
Sky's hilarious.
Or Lady, let's be fair. Um,
I don't want to fin shame
anybody or whatever the fuck
you were talking about it.
Um, but since you're kind enough to do
one of those pussy ass shows of yours,
I will definitely come. I like this
guy breaking fucking balls. Uh,
you, you are going to
love Poland as Yossef.
Polenski used to say it's a great nation.
Only people are constantly,
Whoa, wait a minute,
dude.
Is everybody is funny as you wouldn't,
Poland is just going to be another fucking
country I go to where I'm just like,
oh my God, these guys remind
me that people I grew up with,
I felt that an Ireland, I felt it
in Scotland. I felt that in India.
Just that, that busted shops ball
break and fucking thing is Mike.
It's my favorite thing in
the world. Um, anyways,
as for the city of Warsaw,
well she's not the prettiest of Gals,
but let's be fair. That bitch, that
bitch went through some shit. Uh,
we are watching American show,
so don't worry about making
your pop culture references.
We're currently watching Alf,
and once we figure out why
those jokes are funny, uh,
we're gonna move on to Frazier.
Dude,
can you please start doing
standup or something?
This is just all of this has just
written really fucking funny. Uh,
you could also consider
renting a helicopter here
since it's much cheaper than
the u s although Polish helicopter, it's
just a horse wearing a windmill hat. Ah,
right.
You had one fucking Polish joke day.
Best wishes to your family and break
your pasty leg on this tour. Ps,
if you're interested
in Soviet bloc history,
God knows I didn't learn about that when
I was growing up. Then you should check.
Okay.
A comedian freeze love.
F R e Z.
L U v talking about his military
service in Berlin during the cold.
Um,
I will definitely check that out and
I'll send out a link to this, uh,
podcast episode here. Um,
Oh, speaking of which,
I've been having the best time
with mercy, right? At first. He,
the one thing I love about Versie
is [inaudible] is [inaudible] okay?
The way man was going to be
Maddie pullovers these rosy,
he's over here wearing his Jordans.
You know,
he's got his fucking Nike track suit
on and we were in Cologne, Germany. Uh,
did I tell you this yet?
I've told them on stage so many times we
were walking over this fucking bridge,
right?
Okay.
Any Cologne, Germany, as I mentioned,
was one of the most bomb
cities in World War II.
So there's not a lot of old stuff
there because it just got destroyed.
But they have this one beautiful church,
right? So we're walking over the bridge.
At first he is going like to
look at that building, man. God,
it's a beautiful building.
It's that building. Beautiful.
And I'm looking at is these cluster of
whatever buildings and in the middle of
it is this amazing church.
So I'm looking at the build is going,
what in the fuck is this guy
saying? Like, well, what building?
Because that building right there,
look, it's fucking the architecture.
It's beauty. It finally
figured out, I was like, dude,
are you talking about the fucking church?
Okay.
And he's like, yeah, that data.
Oh No, I already told this story,
told this story on Thursday.
I'm still giving him shit about that.
It's a great building.
Um,
all right. Oh, by the way, Versie
Versie two Sicilian in Greek.
He loved the vendors that sell too.
And he's actually really enjoying, uh,
Germany too, which made me happy. Cause
sometimes there's Mediterranean guys,
you know,
they get all fucking upset about the
food and this is no sunshine and Shit,
you know? But he's been having a great
time. All right. Gypsies. Hey there,
Billy bloated brotts uh,
I go to Romania.
Oh,
this is what I was talking about.
We're learning that Gypsy
is considered a racial slur.
Yeah.
All right. Listen to this
first sentence. He goes,
I go to Romania frequently for work and
I'm quite versed in Gypsies and why it
is a racial slur.
Okay.
Uh, in order to live about that
was he still used the word gypsy.
That's like if I was in
America being like a,
hey everybody, uh, for when
you traveled to America,
I've been to east St Louis and I'm
quite versed and Edwards and why it's a
racial slur. Like I wouldn't do that.
That's kind of what he just did there. Uh,
first Rome, Romanians are
Gypsies. Roman people.
Romanian people are descendants of Romans.
I didn't know that.
Gypsies are people that came from Egypt.
Uh,
if you want to insult a Romanian
person called them a gypsy,
okay.
Gypsy stick to themselves and rob.
Slash steal from outsiders.
They will fight at the drop of a hat.
I saw two old lady,
Gypsies fighting over which corner they
were selling flowers on in the old city
in Bucharest.
I hope this clears it up a little.
Now it that didn't clear anything up.
Um,
now I know that Romanians are Roman
and Gypsies are people are from Egypt.
I do know that.
And then you went on to fucking trash him
in a way that I'm sure they were upset
about. I Dunno. Jesus Christ. Did I just
get in trouble just by fucking reading it.
So they got a lot of fight
them. All right. What are
you gonna do? I mean, we've,
I've seen these videos of two San people
dressed up like Santa Claus beating the
fuck out of each other in
my country. Uh, all right.
But I didn't realize that Romanians,
but almost it says Roman in there.
Okay.
Did Not know that. All right. I'll have
to look a lot of that up. Double check,
which means I'm not going to do it.
I'll forget about it.
And then the information you just told me,
we'll be in my head and one
day I'm going to spew it out,
but I'm probably gonna get in trouble. All
right. Recent breakup. Am I the asshole?
Well, firstly, first of all, first dilly.
What two words did I just,
first of all,
it's certainly, I don't know
what the fuck up though. Anyways,
my girlfriend of three years
broke up with me over something.
Me and my family thinks is stupid.
All right,
so right now I'm a little nervous here.
You know if families back in you,
you know,
or you're not one of those fucking young
kids that can do no wrong you anyways.
We are both 20 and since last February
we've been so what generation are you,
is that generation z?
We are about 20 and since last February
we've been arguing since we invited her
to my birthday dinner and she got upset
because she was expected to pay for her
own meal. All right. Who?
Who am I? Who's, who's her?
Is that your girlfriend?
Okay.
I didn't tell my parents until months
later because they didn't want to start
anything. Anyway, around early December,
my family asked me to invite
her to come up with us too.
My Dad's parents home or the 29th
because that's when we could celebrate
Christmas with them. When
I texted her, she said,
am I going to have to pay for my own gas?
I have a s d I don't know what that means,
so I assumed I was missing something.
So I do. Do you have like a
d to the point that you have?
Don't have the fucking time to write,
add Reynaga to look up fucking eight ASD,
all saints disease,
a s d
you are not connected to them.
You are not a winner. All right?
I don't know what the fuck that is.
I don't give a shit.
I'll learn about it later. Um, I have
ASD, so I assumed I was missing something.
So I asked my dad and he said,
of course
she flipped out about it.
I was that Berger's disease.
Would that be a B, d or is that
antilock brakes? I don't fucking know.
Uh, that's ABS. She flipped
out about it became,
and it became the new thing we could
argue about her mom and her sister agree
with her that it's Shitty to not pay
for someone's gas when you invite them
someplace. But my dad's parents
didn't pay for our guests.
Okay.
But no one we know asked for that.
And all of our family members,
we invite to be day dinners.
Never complained about
paying their own bill.
Should I put pun not intended?
I'd appreciate your advice, sir.
And I'm a big fan. You seem pretty
good with your response in most cases.
I should note that after
breaking up with me on New Year's
despite, all right. That's how we ended
it. I don't understand what's going on.
And you guys sound like a bunch of cheap
fucking assholes, green, honest with you.
If you take somebody out
for their fucking birthday,
you make them pay for their birthday
dinner. That's fucking terrible.
It's so terrible. It's
like, it's hilarious.
And I'm sorry she didn't give
a fuck about paying for gas.
She's probably alluding to the fact.
Did you,
did you wait or pay for her own fucking
birthday? That's fucking hilarious.
Okay.
Dan, in a lot of ways is Sanger did
going out to dinner by yourself for your
birthday,
cause at least nobody there.
It's a restaurant knows
that your birthday now,
you sitting there with a table full of
people that know it's your birthday and
now you got to kick in. Wow, man. Yeah.
I should probably stop short of calling
you and your whole family a bunch of
cheap fucks. But let's just say you're
a little rough around the edges. Uh,
okay.
But whatever.
That's water under the bridge.
I guess you need to find your soul mate.
The kind of woman that doesn't mind
paying for own birthday dinner. We don't,
maybe you're a feminist,
you know,
cause most guys who we pay for
our own shit on our birthdays,
we have to go out and go buy the big
fucking fancy gift on Valentine's Day.
I Dunno, I can't figure that one out. And
the fact that you stopped mid sentence,
like she fucking showed up your place
and club you to death and then hit send.
So the forensics couldn't figure
out what time you died. Well,
he did send it email. Alright.
Lesbian dating with no spark.
All right,
well whatever the fuck you're dating,
if there's no spark and out of it, uh, he
built, I was wondering if you wouldn't,
dia could give me some dating
advice to a lady listener. Well,
unfortunately he is not here,
so you're going to have to deal with
my dumb fucking ideas. Uh, I've been,
I've got out odd seven really good
dates with a wonderful woman who was
essentially everything I've ever looked
for in a partner. She's Hilarious,
witty, playful, beautiful,
smart and motivated and
good, kindhearted person. Um,
are you fucking my wife? Sorry.
Uh, the way we have ridiculous,
Witty Banter reminds me of how you
are near or on the podcast. Well,
that's what reminded me when you said it.
Uh,
it turns out we even want all the same
things in life in terms of a long term
relationship for how does this go left?
Did you finally get her naked and
she had a dick? I mean, what is,
what is going on here?
Uh, wanting a family,
living close to parents and siblings
in the same area we grew up. However,
the past few days she's grown
a little distant. Uh, Jesus.
Yeah.
When I asked her why,
she explained that although she really
enjoys spending time with me and that
I've done nothing wrong, she's never felt
strong, passionate feelings toward me.
Uh, okay. This is how you got to
walk somebody through their feelings.
I'll go ahead.
This is never fun.
I responded honestly that
I have not necessarily felt
that huge passenger spark.
Oh, wait a minute. I read it right.
Oh,
she said she never felt strong,
passionate feelings toward me.
Oh, I thought you meant
she's never felt that before.
And she was scared that she loves you.
So she's saying like,
you're cool but I'm not failing.
I responded honestly that I have not
necessarily Sara's Sara Lee felt that huge
pastoring spark with her
eating well congratulations.
What you guys have on your hands
is, is your your fuck buddies? Okay.
And now when you're in an area of limbo
and we don't really know where to go
from here,
I think it's clear that we are attracted
to each other and very compatible,
but there is a lack of clear
chemistry between us. Uh,
she has an a celebrated online
class for the next two weeks.
So we decided to cool things down and
meet again after that is finished.
I think that's very wise.
My question is,
if you consider an emotional,
passionate drive necessarily necessary
for two people to beat together
successfully long term and
how it was with you when Nia,
I am personally a believer in longterm
love growing over time and that put
passionate love and my
experience generally follows
the Newtonian rule of what
comes up must always come down.
Lovely wishes to you,
Nia and the your little one
and go fuck yourself. Um,
I think that the fact that you guys both
had that really mature conversation,
neither one of you is feeling
a spark. It's just like,
you know, in the beginning,
if there's the spark,
there's that,
that's that euphoria that you kind of
chase for the rest of your relationship
because you know, you just get
used to each other. And then
when the love comes out,
it's usually if vacation holiday or if
you've been through something together
and you survived it,
it brings you closer together.
And then you have like these memories.
MMM.
You know, like I've gone
through rough periods, you know,
with my wife and like having a kid
just upsets the whole apple cart.
And,
uh,
you're focusing so much on the kid that
you can kind of like forget to check in
with each other and um,
okay.
You know,
so what I've learned with her as we
have to take like these little weekend
vacations, you know, in town, just
go to a hotel and it's hilarious.
And then we are instantly
fall back in love again.
And then spent the rest of the time
looking at pictures of our daughter,
seeing how we miss her and stuff.
So um,
I dunno,
I think because you guys have,
you guys seem like you should
be really good friends,
but the weirdest thing is you
already bagged or whatever.
So I don't know how that
works in the lesbian world,
but I know in the a Hetero
world that can get weird
and it's kind of 50, 50,
sometimes the guy gets weird,
sometimes the woman gets weird.
It's just kind of weird. So I dunno.
I think it's probably a good thing that
you guys aren't going to see each other
for a couple of weeks and he
can kind of be like, you know,
cause it's early on. Just see where the
fuck you are after two weeks. But, um,
I dunno,
I think you're doing it right.
Like I don't want to think
about that shit, you know,
which is why he probably
asked me to chime in too.
To be honest with you.
The only way that it's
going to fuck at work is a
yeah.
Is it,
you do have that spark in the beginning
because that sparks is what's gonna make
you stay.
Cause if you don't have that spark and
he'd get married for the fucking reasons
or whatever, that it's just
like, you know, you see it,
people marry for money and they're
sitting on a fucking yacht and they're
miserable. Uh, all right. Grown
man's sitting while piercing.
Oh Jesus Christ. It's one of the
worst images I've ever heard.
Dear old Billy blue hills.
Um,
I'm a 40 year old man
with three young children.
I realized the other day that over the
past couple of years I've been sitting
down when I piss more off the they're
not all right now this is funny cause if
you're doing it because you're tired,
it's just fucking hilarious.
I was worried that you were going to,
this is going to be some other
progressive thing that, you know,
standing, Piss, privileged, whatever the
fuck they going to come up with next. Um,
it all started when the kids were babies.
My wife would wake up to feed and I would
head down to the kid like a Zombie to
piss and I was too damn tired.
Just standard AME.
Now the kids are a little older and I'm
still fucking exhausted most of the time
at home that I find myself
sitting down to piss all the time.
I think I'm just tired as fuck.
Am I crazy to assume this is common
among thing among men my age with young
children now that you are 50, do you do
the same? I can't be the only one. Right.
Thanks. Love the podcast and go
fuck yourself. No, I don't do that.
The only time I ever do that is if,
okay.
My wife's sleeping and when we
lived in smaller apartments,
I didn't want to wake her up. When I
was taking a piss out of consideration,
I would sit down and that
would always make me laugh.
And I would always picture
all of my friends making
fun of me that I was sitting
down. Well, well, uh,
I think the fact that you still
say pissing rather than paying,
which is one of my major pet peeves,
uh,
I can meet with a guy says
I have to go pee. It's just,
I can't even tell you my body like
microscopic leap, like could torts.
MMM.
Oh by the way, somebody told
me it's anyway and not anyways.
And I have to tell you, I don't
give a shit. I like say it anyways.
I say it in a plural sense.
MMM.
No,
you probably not the only one who does it.
Uh,
but I will tell you that.
Okay.
What I have learned just having one
kid is how important it is to get eight
hours of really good sleep.
And you should watch TV and
be on your fucking phone.
I've actually gone back to reading. If you
consider reading sports books, reading,
I try to read,
but my wife,
she always watches the fucking real
housewives or that tattoo parlor show it,
you know,
any show that involves people.
She doesn't care about screaming
at each other for some reason.
She loves to watch that
before she goes to bed. Um,
so I just put on these, the fucking same
headphones I wear when I fly in a plane,
so I can't hear people and I
just read the fucking book.
Uh,
but anyways, I think maybe if you
get eight hours sleep, you know,
you hit the gym a little
bit if you have time. But I,
I know how tired I am with one kid.
I can't imagine with like three at a
good friend of my life told me one time
when he was talking about being a parent.
His kids are older,
he's got like two or three kids
and three kids and he said,
uh, he goes, dude, he goes,
I've been tired since the 90s.
So I think that's just what it is.
Uh,
that's just what it is.
And you know what it is.
Cause once you kids get older and they
can kind of take care of themselves,
meaning they can wake up, brush their
teeth, get ready for school at all,
that you feel like you're
not going to be tired.
But I think the thing that makes you
tired is the worry because you constantly
fucking worried that something's going
to happen to him. But whatever. Um,
all right, that's the podcast. Apologize
for the low volume of talking here.
I really want to thank everybody that's
come out to my shows here in Germany.
I could not have had a better
time. Uh, it was fucking awesome.
And uh, I will definitely be back the next
time. Hopefully when I get a new hour,
you guys still want to come to see me?
I will definitely be back.
I think I'll come during the summer
months, next time or October fest.
One or the other.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday.